hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cards against
humanity i'm joined by ethan and tylor
that's right we're here yes they are
introduce yourselves
hi i'm ethan i'm tylor
the lord of the ties
i'm not lord of anything i'm just little
old me
that's okay someday you'll be a big boy
and you'll be able to
well yeah once puberty hits
[Music]
anyway so we're going to play cards
against humanity and uh
what we're going to do here is nothing
special there's nothing to this we're
not special nothing here is special
we're going to play
regular old cards against humanity so
who's ready i'm ready
all right i'm ready everyone deal
yourself seven
i think i think that's right yeah seven
no no
what what okay no did not straight in a
row yes
okay i said look we can do this just put
it back on there
then you take yeah then i take
then you that then you then me
[Music]
uh
well i think it varies based upon the
amount of people you're playing
with seven also i want to mention if
anyone's noticing the grime residue on
this particular table
this isn't the table that tyler smashed
with a sledgehammer nor is it the table
that i
crashed into many times but uh
bad boy yeah pink
[Laughter]
you can still see like the crust oh man
that has turned into something
oh yeah it it stunk any of this black
mold
that could kill us dead oh i don't think
so that'd be fun that'd be a
so anyway if you don't have cards
against humanity
[Music]
you're making me want to like learn how
to glitch so i can gleak
don't do this you love to use the word
gleek
have you ever thought about writing
poetry i have yeah
it never works what happened uh you won
did i totally i don't know
we did the same
during high school i never really fit in
until i found
blank club are you guys in any clubs in
school i wish
i wish i would and women yeah i did
theater and
improv oh i wish we had improv club
yeah that would have been the greatest
thing i know we had it at uc but i never
even thought of doing it probably at the
time even though i loved
whose line anyway you're during high
school i never really fit in
until i found fisting club
during high school i never really fit in
until i found total
[ __ ] chaos club that sounds awesome
i never really fit in until i found
getting hilariously gang-banged by the
blue man group club
i really like total [ __ ] chaos that's
not my final decision but i just imagine
kids just
in class just like pushing people over
like
taking like axe body spray and making
like the flame throwers
it's you with your half shave ball
i'm gonna go with total [ __ ] chaos
club is that rando
who was who were you i was fisting i was
blue man i was hoping you were gonna
catch on with the uh the blue hair
blue man it wasn't the hilarious game
but you know what maybe led
to that one no it was that that's how he
got the blue hair
oh the five stages of grief
denial anger bargaining blank acceptance
you're good okay all right here we go
around a little bit the five state i
didn't see the five stages of grief
denial anger bargaining
slowly easing down on the kick
and then denial anger bargaining
figuring out how to have sex with a
dolphin
acceptance denial anger bargaining
unsheathing my massive horse [ __ ]
i gotta go with cucumber yeah
just like squatting there just
well because you know there has to be an
elaborate cucumber stand
because that's it you know you had to
lube it up you know it's not just gonna
go for that it's an
afternoon of activities this is an
insanity workout shawn do you pop soup
tighten your core
[Laughter]
now relax squeeze relax all right tyler
you're up
hey baby come back to my place and i'll
show you blank
wha what am i showing this baby
oh i don't think it's an actual baby
like an infant
i think it's probably it might be a baby
it could be a baby
hey hey babe hey baby hey baby come back
to my place i gotta show you this
thing baby come on baby
baby's not listening hey baby come back
to my place and i'll show you my
preteens
or show you preteens they're not mine i
don't know i'm just showing you pretty
jeans
your assortment in your closet oh that's
good that's that's like super
like a tie rack you push a button
[Laughter]
i'll show you peen into a girl's butt
baby that's how you were made baby i'm
showing you how to do it baby
this is the birds and the bees talk and
then the other one is a horse with no
[Music]
that's legs this isn't my final decision
but without the description this is
this is the funnier one i just think
this is funny because i said baby to be
enough
okay cool thank you i was the horse with
no legs
that's funny to you yeah that was this
work
it's like it's gonna die just like what
if
what if someone was like hey i got
something to show you and they just draw
back a curtain it's just a [ __ ] horse
with no legs
of course it's on its side okay here's
to fix
the visual i imagine it is somehow in a
custom-made saddle
on another horse
[Laughter]
it's a horse with no legs and it's in
one of those like baby bouncy things
everybody join hands and close your eyes
do you sense that
that's the presence of blank in this
room everybody join hands and close your
eyes do you sense that that's the
presence
of deez nuts in this room
that's the presence of crying and
[ __ ] and eating spaghetti
in this room that's the presence of lots
and lots of abortions
[Laughter]
i really like how specific crying and
[ __ ] and eating spaghetti
is that's really funny i'm gonna go with
lots and lots of abortions thank you
don't worry guys just imagine that
they're legless babies
listen son if you want to get involved
with blank i won't stop you just steer
clear of blank
listen son if you want to get involved
with an inability to form meaningful
relationships
i won't stop you just steer clear of two
whales [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of each
other
[Music]
okay that would be a sight you know i
wouldn't mind seeing two whales [ __ ]
just because i don't know how they'd do
it because they like
sideways i don't think that that's
possible for whales to
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of each other to like
have aggressive sex like i don't think
that's possible with their size and like
the water
yeah like to go that fast i don't think
that's possible i want to see like
two that are [ __ ] so fast and sploosh
out of the water
he gooshes
wait wait what if the original form of
why [ __ ] is called a [ __ ] as a
whale [ __ ] another whale's blowhole
ow no what if i [ __ ] your nose
your nose no there's probably people
that are
into that [ __ ] whales blow hole
like that dude one of those things i
mean when you think about anything
sexually there's one person out there
that's like they're into that all right
listen son if you want to get involved
with the boners of the elderly
i won't stop you just steer clear of my
dad's dumb
[ __ ] face so don't look
your grandpa in the eye when you're
getting all up in his
boner
i get that that's that's a good one
that's a good pair listen son if you
want to get involved with
seeing things from hitler's perspective
just i won't stop you just you're clear
of no longer finding any cards against
humanity cards funny that
is exactly what i was not hoping for i
was like
please be a funny follow-up
oh no oh i got a bonus yeah
i didn't have anything to follow up but
i thought the beginning was good oh
yeah oh yeah it's just like this is an
antithesis
card it's good but oh man the secret to
a lasting marriage
is communication communication and blank
secret to a lasting marriage i almost
said fisting marriage why
can't i read right now is communication
communication and
being nine years old a gender identity
that can only be conveyed through slam
poetry
the size of my payments
all good yeah
i like to communicate through the size
of my penis if you guys didn't know that
i didn't you didn't no you do you want
to communicate later
dude totally what left this stain on my
couch
mark trying to communicate with me
dang it i just drew this one i wanted to
use it oh no
guys don't you hate it when you're
playing cards against humanity and you
just play a card and then you draw the
perfect card
i hate it i hate it i forgot i had that
card that would have been better than
what i played
what left this stain on my couch that
ass
what left this stain on my couch
unquestioning obedience
what left the stand on my accounts
prince ali fabulous
[Laughter]
who i could go with the aladdin one
is that randy that was me no that wasn't
funny until you read it like that
just like the pauses between them
prince ollie fabulous so cruel
i didn't think it was funny regardless
but that
worked out i don't know man this is
prince ellie
fabulousy
my mom freaked out when she looked at my
browser history and found
blank.com slash
blank my mom freaked out when she looked
at my browser history and found
a sad fat dragon with no friends dot com
slash
lock chalk
catastrophic urethraltrauma.com slash
an unstoppable wave of fire ants
oh my god was that just a website where
it's different
versions of your ethical trust daddy
issues dot com slash
maximal insertion yikes
it's a tight one between
wrong words i gotta go with daddy issues
[Music]
what are the standings right now tyler
[Laughter]
because i got another one i want to play
we'll just do a double round i'll put
another ring
because this one's got a lot of good
ones all right so we got six cards in
this particular one
this is too much goodness
all right when i pooped what came out my
butt first
brown crusty [ __ ]
free ice cream yo
8th graders
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i think even randa stepped up to the
plate here
a sex goblin where the carnival being
me you're pooping out [ __ ]
i really like eighth grade
that's gross it's not even my card
i think this weighs oh is that right the
goblin penis yeah that's random damn
i just picture like a tiny little goblin
coming out and standing on my turns
on your turns turds in the toilet
you don't think eighth graders pooping
out your butt
i thought that was worrying he's like in
an
interview room in the police stage and
he's like what can i
poop man we found the eighth graders
this is
the free ice cream was my other one that
was the one
i liked
[Laughter]
what's that sound all right what's that
sound daddy's smell
what's that sound [ __ ] mountain
what's that sound a face full of horrors
come
it's between daddy's belt and the [ __ ]
mountain
i'm gonna go with daddy's belt oh yeah i
would have gone with [ __ ]
that's random that was random just off
in the distance like
we're approaching it this is [ __ ]
what ended my last relationship
[Music]
was it the way white people is
was it my worthless son was it
ejaculating live
bees and the bees are angry
that's like a trump card that's a trump
card
[Music]
all right the standings are tyler's at
last with two
you've got two two three i've got four
so i could win it right here but we
shall see the ciaa
now interrogates enemy agents by
repeatedly subjecting them to blank
by repeatedly subjecting them into an
overwhelming
variety of cheeses beloved television
store bill cosby
[Laughter]
cause that's been going on for like what
five years now
it's been a while yeah so anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching this
was fun
yeah yeah charge against humanity is
always fun it was a good round
good cards all around i liked it a lot
and uh thank you again everybody for
watching if you play cards against
humanity at home uh
remember to have fun with it don't take
it too seriously and uh be as offensive
as you want to be because it's a safe
space so
thank you ethan for joining me you can
find his channel down in the description
thank you tyler also you can find his
twitter and his
baron video list youtube channel down
there as well
there's nothing there no hopes no dreams
but subscribe anyway
because it's an experiment he's trying
to do a hundred thousand
no videos is it possible who knows
now it is
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always we'll see you
in the next video bye-bye
bye